[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا
الكرام في حرب تشرين عام
73 كان السوريون يصفقون لصواريخ سامر
التي كانت تصطاد الطائرات الاسرائيليه فوق
سوريا كالعصافير
لكن ملايين السوريين اليوم سيصف قون لاي
صاروخ يسقط الطائرات الروسيه التي تقصف
المدنيين السوريين من ادلب حتى
درعا لماذا اصطفت روسيا بكل قوتها
السياسيه والعسكريه الى جانب طاغيه طائفي
فاشي للقضاء على ثوره شعب
الا تستهدف كل الفصائل التي تواجه جيش
الاسد باستمناء
داعش اليس هناك اجماع دولي على ان 5% فقط
من الغارات الروسيه تستهدف داعش اليست
غالبيه ضحايا الغزو الروسي من المدنيين في
المدارس والمساجد والاحياء
السكنيه كيف تدعو روسيا الى حل سياسي في
سوريا وهي تقف الى جانب النظام بكل ما
اوتيت من
على من
تضحك لكن في المقابل اليس هناك مباركه
عربيه ودوليه للتدخل الروسي في سوريا الا
تتعرض روسيا لحمله شيطنه اعلاميه دوليه
الا تركز على مناطق الارهابيين فقط الم
يقل الروس انهم قضوا على معظم قوه داعش
الا يمدون ايديهم لكل فصائل المعارضه بما
فيها الجيش الحر اليست روسيا الاكثر صدقا
في تصريحاتها وتعاملها مع الازمه السوريه
اليس من يسمون باصدقاء سوريا مثل اصدقاء
الفيسبوك لا تحصل منهم الا على اللايكات
فقط اليس من الاجحاف اتهام روسيا بان لا
مانع لديها من تهجير كل الشعب السوري
طالما استولت على ثروات الغاز والنفط في
سوريا بتسهيل من ال الاسد اسئله اطرحها
على الهواء مباشره على السيناتور الدكتور
سبسبي نائب رئيس لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه
في مجلس الشيوخ الروسي وعلى الدكتور نصر
الحريري امين عام الائتلاف السوري المعارض
السابق نبدا نقاش بعد
[موسيقى]
الفاصل اه بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام
نحن معكم على الهواء مباشره في برنامج
الاتجاه المعاكس بامكانكم التصويت على
موضوع هذه الحلقه
هل تؤيد الحله السياسيه الروسيه في
سوريا نعم 9.8 لا 90.2 دكتور زياد لو بدات
معك بهذه الشريحه بهذا الاستفتاء في
الشارع العربي اكثر من
90% لا يؤمنون ولا يصدقون ولا يؤيدون ما
تفعله روسيا في سوريا بحجه ايجاد حل انت
تعلم الان ان الجانب الاكبر من السوريين
وغير
السوريين حولت روسيا في نظرهم الى عدو
مبين يعني انتم ضحيتم بعلاقتهم التاريخيه
مع الشعوب العربيه ومع الشعب السوري خصوصا
من اجل نظام زائل لا
محاله مساء الخير اولا طبعا هذا الكلام
غير صحيح ا جمله وتفصيلا ايه التدخل
الروسي في سوريا لم ياتي لكي يدافع عن
نظام الحكم في سوريا وانما اتى اي ونابع
من حمايه المصالح الروسيه في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط ولحمايه الحدود
الجنوبيه لروسيا نحن نذكر جميعا التهديدات
التي اصدرتها اصدرها تنظيم داعش عندما هدد
ب العوده او عندما ينتهي من احلال الخلافه
في سوريا وفي بلاد الشام سوف يتوجه الى
روسيا وخاصه الى منطقه شمال القوقاز هذه
التهديدات لم تكن تهديدات من قبل اطفال
وانما كانت ترتكز على معلومات
استخباراتيه جديه بان هنالك توجه لرجوع
الجهاديين الى روسيا والى بلاد الدول
المستقله سابقا واريد ان انوه بان عدد
المقاتلين اليوم من روسيا ومن دول الاتحاد
السوفيتي السابق تجاوز 4000 مقاتل وهذا
رقم كبير في معادله ومخيف وشكل خطرا بس
خليني استفسر منك عن نقطتين سريعا مشان ما
يروحوا فورا انت تقول نحن لا ندافع عن
نظام بل ندافع عن مصالحنا ونحن خائفون ولا
نريد للدواعش ان يعودوا ليقاتل كما كانوا
يفعلون في الشيشان طيب لكن نحن سمعنا من
الرئيس الروسي نفسه بوتين في لقائه مع
السي بي اس يقول نحن ذاهبون الى سوريا
لدعم النظام السوري في مواجهه الارهاب نحن
ذاهبون لدعم بشار الاسد هذه من جهه من جهه
ثانيه طيب اذا انتم فعلا عازمون على
مقاتله داعش لماذا لم تذهبوا الى العراق
بالمناسبه داعش الموجوده في سوريا عباره
عن لعب عيال بالمقارنه مع داعش الموجوده
في العراق فاذا هذا ينسف كل الكذبه بتاعكم
سوري يعني
ا لكل سؤال جواب تفضل والجواب دائما نحن
نعتمد الى ارقام والى وقائع وليس الى
دعايات اعلاميه السيد الرئيس بوتين عندما
قال نحن اتينا الى روسيا لندعم الى الى
سوريا لندعم النظام كان يقصد لدعم الحكومه
الشرعيه المتواجده اليوم في دمشق والتي
تقوم في محاربه داعش والمنظمات الارهابيه
الاخرى روسيا الان وقد اعلنت سابقا بانها
جاهزه ايضا لمحاربه داعش في العراق ولكن
كما نعلم بان الامريكيين يمارسون الارهاب
الدولي وقد هددوا الحكومه العراقيه بانه
اذا كان هنالك او اذا وافقت الحكومه
العراقيه على دخول روسيا على الخط في
محاربه داعش فسوف تعتزر الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه عن تقديم المساعدات العسكريه من
ناحيه تقديم الخبراء او من ناحيه تقديم
الاسلحه روسيا جاهزه للتدخل ايضا في
العراق لمحاربه داعش هنالك تفويض للرئيس
الروسي بوتين يحتاج فقط الى موافقه والى
طلب خطي من الحكومه العراقيه للتدخل
لمحاربه الارهابيين في العراق دكتور كيف
ترد على هذا الكلام روسيا من حقها ان تكون
هناك الان وكما قال قال نحن لا يعني نحن
اتينا لاسباب جوهريه نحن خائفون نحن نريد
ان ندافع عن مصالحنا وعن امننا القومي
بالدرجه الاولى ولا تنسى ماذا فعل
الشيشانيون بروسيا لفتره طويله من الزمن
مما اضطر الرئيس الروسي الى تسويه جروزني
بالارض على طريقه الحرب العالميه الثانيه
اذا هناك خوف حقيقي كيف ترد يعني اولا
الروس طلقوا فتره طويله من علاقات كانت
موجوده وكان الشعب السوري يكن كل الاحترام
وكل المحبه وكل التقدير للروس الروس هم
اعداء للشعب السوري وهم وقفوا الى جانب
النظام السوري ليس بحجه الارهاب فقبل ظهور
داعش مرت شهور طويله على الثوره السوريه
كان النظام يقتل فيها المتظاهرين السلميين
بالبنادق ثم بالمدافع ثم بالدبابات ثم
بالطائرات قبل ان يظهر داعش وان يظهر اي
تطرف هذا اولا اثنين ان مصالح اي دوله هي
تكون مع مصلحه الشعب وتتعامل مع الش
الشعوب التي تولد الحكومات وليس مع نظام
متهاوي نظام مستبد نظام ديكتاتور اليوم
اصبح في عزله امام العالم تقريبا اغلبه ان
لم يكن كله ومعروف ان هذا النظام ذاهب
باتجاه الجحيم وباتجاه النهايه ولولا هذه
هذا الجحيم وهذه النهايه ما تدخلت روسيا
اصلا وانا بالنسبه للتدخل الروسي او
الاحتلال الروسي اليوم انا لا اذهب الى
تحليلات اذهب الى احتلال الروسي بكل معنى
الكلمه انا لا اذهب الى تحليلات اذهب الى
ما قال الرئيس بوتن نفسه قال نحن تدخلنا
لتعزيز قدر بشار الاسد ولحمايه بشار الاسد
من الانهيار ثانيا اليوم صار لنا شهر
واربعه ايام على الاحتلال الروسي المناطق
التي تقصف حمس حماء حلب ادلب اللاذقيه 5%
اليوم قد تكون ارتفعت امبارح بقصف مهين
الى يعني ما يقارب 10% من المناطق التي
استهدفها الروس لتخفيف هذا الضغط الاعلامي
العالمي عليهم بانه انت داعش بانه انتوا
اخي عم تقصف الارهاب هذا كلام كذب قصفته
في تير م تير معلى المخابز في احسم عائله
نزحت من من قضيه س بسبب القصف الروسي الى
مزرعه دواجن مزرعه لا تليق بالحياه
البشريه وليست فيها اي مؤهلات يعيش فيها
انسان اجا الطيران الروسي وقصف هي مزرعه
الدواجن المليئه بالارهابيين ارهابيين صف
خامس ارهابيين صف سادس ارهابيين صف سابع
يعني بتعرف مزرعه بتفرخ ارهابيين عائله
عساف عائله عساف كامله 47 شخص انقرض هذه
العائله عن وجه البشريه عن وجه الارض ليش
لانه الروس عم يقصفوا الارهابيين ه الحجه
اصبحت مكشوفه واصبحت بائسه واذا كانت
روسيا تريد ان تبني شركات لحرب داعش
فلتتفضل وتفرجنا قوات النظام تروح تقاتل
داعش بدير الزور اللي صار لها ثلاث سنين
الحمد لله رب العالمين مو قادر النظام
يخلص داعش بدير الزور خلي بدل ما سونا درع
الجزيره ودرع السويده ودرع ساحل ودرع درعا
ودرع الشام خلي يساوي درع واحد لداع
يفرجينا النظام اليوم انه هو عم يدخل في
حرب حقيقيه مع داعش اما اخي الكريم روسيا
اليوم تنفذ اجندات واضحه مهمتها حمايه
بشار الاسد بعد الانهيار السريع والمفاجئ
واللي كان خارج التوقعات اللي حدث بالفتره
الاخيره تصور انه اللواء 52 وحضرتك من
السويده وتعرفه ثاني اكبر لواء دفاع جوي
في سوريا سقط خلال خمس ساعات يعني صار
الشباب سوبر ستار يعني كانك عم تلعب اتاري
ولا شغله مع نظام بشار الاسد محافظه ادلب
محافظه كامله تسقط على يد ابطال الجيش
الحر جسر الشغور 250 واحد من النظام لم
يكترث بهم ابدا وكان مستعد لفنا جميعا
وفني اغلبهم بس لمجرد انه ما يقولوا نظام
بشار الاسد انهزم اللعبه اليوم صارت
مكشوفه والدفاع عن نظام بشار الاسد لن
يجلي بشار الاسد اصبح عباره عن هيكل
كرتوني يحمل بطائرات الشحن يعني يحمل مثل
البضاعه يعني مثل شده السفر يحمل اليوشن
بروح على موسكو وب يرجع من موسكو يعني حتى
يا سيدي الكريم احنا بشار الاسد هو يفترض
انه سوري واخي ننا بعناه ما عاد بدنا اياه
اخي اللي مشترينه يحترموه شوي يعني
يحترموه يعاملوه كرئيس حتى اذا بدهم
يتعاملوا معه كورقه تفاوضيه يا اخي غلي
ورقتك مو حاط لي اياه قدامك كانه طالب
راسب بامتحانات او متهم عم تقاضيه بجريمه
لا معه وفد لا معه وزير خارجيه لا معه
وزير دفاع لا معه علم حتى على ما يمكن كان
بده يروح يقضي الزلم حاجته ما سمحوا له
لانه كان كان في خوف حقيقي اذا يعني بيتسر
انه بشار الاسد فعلا طالع من دمشق من
سوريا ما عاد يرجع لها ابدا ما عاد يرجع
لها ابدا لذلك ما كان اعلان عن عودته الا
عن زيارته الا بعد ما تم العوده مصلحه
روسيا اليوم وهي رساله انقلها لمجلس
الدومه مصلحه روسيا اليوم ان تبني علاقات
مع الشعب السوري مع مكونات الشعب السوري
الذي ثار ضد هذا النظام السنه ثاروا
والعلويين ثاروا والضابط الذي تكلمت قبل
قليل عنه في بصر الحرير ظهر في تقرير ضابط
علوي يقاتل الى جانب الجيش الحر وفي غيرهم
والمسيحيين ثاروا والدروز قصه الدروز
اخواننا كلهم اخواننا ان شاء الله واهلنا
وللاسف الشديد انا اتكلم بهذه الصفه لم
يبرزها الا نظام بشار الاسد عشنا كل
حياتنا بسوريا في الجامعه في العسكريه في
المشافي وانا طبيب قلبيه لم نكن نعرف من
هو درزي ومن هو مسيحي ومن هو سني ومن هو
علوي رساله الى مجلس الدومه اليوم ان يبني
علاقته مع الشعب السوري الشعب السوري شعب
واعي قادر ان يجلس على طاوله مفاوضات على
مبدا الم المصلحه المشتركه والمنفعه
المشتركه والمخاوف المشتركه وقادرين ان
نبني علاقه استراتيجيه مع روسيا ومع غيرها
من دول العالم على اساس مصلحتنا ومصلحه
الروس اما تمسكم بهذا النظام المهترئ لن
يسمن ولن يغني من جوع روسيا قالت ننا خلال
خمس ايام قادرين نقلب الموازين والموازين
لسه عقل بالعكسس بالعكس داعش اخذت طيب كيف
ترد على هذا الكلام دكتور سمعته كله او
انا لست في موقع ان ادافع عن نظام الرئيس
السوري في هنالك
يخويا والشبح ستجدوا فيكم وغن عفوا انا لا
اريد ان اخصص الموضوع او تحويل الماسات
السوريه الى
موضوع افلام كرتونيه وجزه كرتونيه لن
اتطرق الى المعارضه المصطنعه التي بالفعل
تم انتاجها في
دواجن المخابر ان كانت الاوروبيه او
الغربيه ولن نتكلم الان عن
و موضوع مرجعيات المعارضه اللي يمكن لها
ان يكون لها دور ما
الكلام انه يجب على روسيا ان تقيم علاقات
مع الشعب السوري نحن نسير في هذا الاتجاه
وموسكو من اليوم الاول كانت ابوابها
مفتوحه واذا انتقلنا مباشره الى الوضع
الحالي في سوريا روسيا رسميا اعلنت بان هي
مستعده ان تكون حليفه ومتعاون مع الجيش
الحر الذي يطالب بالحريه ويطالب بالكرامه
ويريد ايضا ان يحارب الارهابيين ويريد ان
يحارب
داعش من الذي اسقط ادلب او من الذي احتل
ادلب ليس هم الجيش الحر والاستاذ نصر يجب
ان يعرف هي جبهه النصره التي ققام مش جبه
النصره مش جبه النصره لحالها جبهه النصره
فصيل من فصائل كثيره في جيش الفتح من اهم
الفصائل التي كانت في ادلب هي جبهه النصره
والى الان مسيطره على هذا الوضع روسيا لم
ولن تجعل من الشعب السوري عدوا لها في اي
مرحله من المراحل جعلت جعلته طب انا عم
بعطيك عم بعطيك شريحه من من الشارع 90%
ضدكم الان تحولت الى عدو في وا ايضا لدينا
ايضا لدينا احصائيات تقول
العكس لا ليس بالشبيحة
تكلم عن المسيحيين والدروز والعلويين وكل
اطياف الشعب السوري اغلبيه اطياف الشعب
السوري المتواجده الان تعبت واهت من الحرب
وهذا الوضع اليوم الي الذي تسير به
المعارضه انه سوف نقاتل الى اخر سوري والى
اخر جندي هذا كلام عفى عنه الزمن يجب
اليوم على المعارضه ان تقول بانه يجب ونحن
نقول والسيد الرس بوتين قال لا يمكن لنا
عن طريق التدخل العسكري ان نحل الازمه في
سوريا يجب ان يكون هنالك حوارا سياسيا
جادا والافضل ان يبدا به الرئيس بشار
الاسد في هذه اللحظه في في هذه يعني حلم
ابليس بالجنه هذا بشار الاسد انت تعلم لا
يريد اي حوار وقبل ساعات سمعت نائب وزير
الخارجيه السوري فيصل المقداد من طهران
وهو يقول نرفض رفضا قاطعا اه الدخول في
مرحله انتقاليه نحن نتحدث عن حكومه وحده
وطنيه هذول بتاع يعني مثلا المعارضه
بيعطوه وزاره المزابل القوميه والصرف
الصحي مثلا كذا كذا يعني هذا هو الذي
يتحدث عنه بشار الاسد لا لا دكتور دكتور
خلينا نحن بالشو اسمه انا بدي اوجه لك هذا
السؤال ماذا تقول لفيصل مقداد اليوم نائب
وزير الخارجيه السوري عندما يقول لك نحن
نرفض يعني يضرب عرض الحائط بالمقترحات
الروسيه وبعود بالحلول الروسيه قال لك نحن
ضد المرحله الانتقاليه لا نريد اي شيء من
هذا فيك تقول لي الان لفيصل المقداد
كمسؤول روسي تقول له مش على كيفك فيك تقول
له هذا الكلام انا اذكر الدكتور الاستاذ
فيصل المقداد بوثيقه جنيف واحد التي تم
الاتفاق عليها وبوجود الحكومه الروسيه يجب
علينا ان لا نصغر هذا الموضوع المرحله
الانتقاليه وارده في حل الازمه السوريه
اليوم
للاسف كل الجهات تحل المشكله في سوريا ما
عدا السوريين يعني حتى في لقاء فينا لم
يكن هنالك بلا كان كان واحد كان الجرسون
اللي عم ووزع واحد سوري هو الوحيد كان من
اللاجئين يمكن يكون كمان اليوم يجب على
المعارضه ان تتوحد وان يكون لها فريق عمل
واحد واركز على المعارضه في الداخل
المعارضه المتواجده في العواصم الغربيه
والاقليميه ما حول سوريا لن يكون لها دورا
مؤثرا في اتخاذ القرار وتنفيذه داخليا
اليوم على المعارضه الداخليه وخاصه
اي قاده ومقاتلين الجيش الحر ان
يتحدوا بموقف واحد يعني حتى الجيش الحر
اليوم مختلف قياداته مختلفه البعض يريد ان
ينسق مع الروس البعض لا يريد ان ينسق مع
الروس البعض مع مرحله انتقاليه البعض ضد
المرحله
تون انتم تريدون باختصار كي انتقل للدكتور
انتم قادمون الى سوريا لايجاد حل لاخراج
سوريا من محنتها روسيا هي الوحيده التي
تنتفع باستقرار وامان منطقه الشرق الاوسط
وخاصه سوريا سور كيف ترد على هذا الكلام
ما العيب في ذلك انا بسالك سؤال ايضا نعم
نحن نوجه كل هذه اللكمات واللطم الى الى
الى روسيا والروس كذا والروس كذا والروس
كذا الا تعتقد ان الروس حسب ما نرى منذ
بدايه الازمه هم اكثر الاطراف صدقا اه في
تصريحاتهم وفي مواقفهم وفي كل شيء يعني
على الاقل الروس لديهم استراتيجيه واضحه
الان في سوريا حتى لو استخدموا القوه على
عكس اصدقائكم اه ما يسمى باصدقاء سوريا
اللي حكينا قبل شوي والله شو استفدتوا
منهم يعني مثل ما قلنا في المقدمه
اصدقائكم هدول اصدقاء سوريا مثل اصدقاء
الفيسبوك ما بتربح منهم الا اللايكات
فقط يعني اولا بس تعليق شوي على النقاط
اللي
ذكرها الدكتور اولا المعارضه الموجوده في
الخارج هي معارضه ليست مصطنعه هذه
المعارضه فيها من المعارضين القدامى الذين
ناضلوا ضد نظام الدكتاتوريه نظام حافظ
الاسد واعتقلوا عشرات السنين من من
السوريين لا يعرف ميشيل كيلو وجورج صبره
وبرهان غليون ورياض صيف ووالى اخره
العشرات يعني من الناس المعارضين لما كنا
نن نهتف بحياه القائد كانوا هم قابعين في
السجون والمعارضه الموجوده في الخارج فيها
الدكتور جواد ابو حطب الموجود الان في احد
المشافي الله يحميه لا اريد ان اذكره حتى
ما يصبح عرضه للطيران الروسي وفيها الاخ
فيصل الشام موجود في ريف دمشق وفيها الاخ
احمد التيناوي موجود في ريف درعا وفيها
العديد من اعضاء الائتلاف الان الموجودين
داخل الاراضي السوريه ولا يزالوا الى الان
يتبنون مبادئ ثورتهم وقضايا التي تهم
الشعب السوري والفئات التي ذكرها الفئات
قاده الجيش الحر اخواننا ولولاهم ولولا
هذه التضحيات الرائعه ما وصل الشعب السوري
الى مصل من هذا الصمود الى ماذا وصل الشعب
السوري اذا
سحت لم افضل افضل الى ما وصل من هذا
الصمود الاسطوري الراضي عنه هو يعني اليوم
حتى اللاجئين الذين يلجؤون الى دول اوروبا
لازالوا مصممين على استئصال بشار الاسد
ونظامه من سوريا حضرتك الان تحكي عن موضوع
المعارضه وعلاقتها مع الخارج المعارضه
تحاول وانا اشرت ان تبني علاقات
استراتيجيه مع الكل مع من وقف الى جانب
الشعب السوري وان تحدث كذلك تحالفات
استراتيجيه مع ما لا يزال يقف الى جانب
النظال حت مع النظام حتى نصل الى تسويه
عادله ومقبوله وم روسيا بما فيهم روسيا
وكان هناك عده زيارات للاخوه منذ تاسيس
المجلس الوطني واثناء الائتلاف وكان
الموقف الروسي كما ذكرت صادقا الحقيقه في
الجريمه في الوقوف الى جانب نظام بشار
الاسد فدعم بغطاء سياسي فيتو عده مرات حتى
لا تتم اي ادانه لنظام بشار الاسد ودعمه
بالسلاح ودعمه بالمال والان في احتلال
علني بعد ان انهارت قوات نظام بشار الاسد
روسيا مستعده ان تكون حليفه مع الجيش الحر
يعني والله الانسان بده يكون شوي بس يعني
شوي منطقي دكتور تحتر عقولنا هل اليوم من
يبحث عن حليف يقصف في المخابز والمساجد
والمدارس ومزارع الدجاج ومزارع الحيوانات
يقصفوا اينما كان يقول له اخي تعال بعدين
غريب فعلا شيء غريب الروس عايشين ب حاله
تخبط وانا طبيب قلبيه وطبيب باطنه واعرف
في حاله تخليط وهذيان مش طبيعيه بنفس
اليوم اين هم الجيش الحر ما في جيش حر كله
ارهابي اخي اللي بيقاتل ضد بشار الاسد
هذول دواعش وارهابيين لازم نتخلص منهم
وبعد بعد ساعتين بطلع بقول لي خيو اين
الجيش الحر بدنا نحن نتفاوض مع الجيش الحر
والجيش الحر رح يجيك لانه انت ذكرت معركه
ادلب راح اذكر لك الجيش الحر من احتل ادلب
سيدي ليس احتل ادلب هو حررها من براثن هذا
العدوان المجرم نعم وادلب وحضرتك بمحافظه
حلب وحلب قريبه جدا من ادلب واهل ادلب
واهل حلب هم واحد مثل كل اهل سوريا بتعرف
لو يعني لو مطلع انت على وقائع الامور في
بلدك تعرف انه ادلب تحررت من قبل فيلق
لواء حق في ادلب وهو ابو عارف غزال الله
يحميهم جميعا وفيه اجناد حماه وفيه فيلق
الشام و احرار الشام يا سيدي العزيز جبهه
النصره لا تشكل في جيش الفتح اكثر من 13%
بالنسبه المئويه من يحرر الاراضي طيب سؤال
معركه حماه هل سمعت معركه حماه 28 مدرعه
ودبابه قصفت على يد ابطال الثوار على
الارض وكانت صاعقه وصدمه للروس بداوا
يتخبطون بعدها هذه المعركه في حماه من قال
من قام بالمعركه اول فصيل قصف على يد
القوات الروسيه الغاشمه هو تجمع كتائب
العزه وبعدها صقور الغاب وصقور جبل
الزاويه وهذه الفصائل متعارف عليها كل دول
العالم ان هذه الفصائل معتمده ولها علاقات
دوليه وتجلس معهم على طاولات ويعرفونه
ويعرفوا بعض بشكل جيد ايه لن نجعل الاسد
حليف كمان هذا الامر اخي مخالف للواقع ام
اليوم تصفيه اعداء الاسد ومن يسعى للتخلص
من نظام بشار الاسد وتقويه النظام لا ينم
عن انه في نيه فعلا روسيه حقيقيه الى انه
تبني تحالف مع الشعب السوري الاطياف
السوريه التي تعبت من الحرب نعم ونحن
تعبنا من الحرب انا طبيب قلبيه كنت اداوم
بمشف كنت فخور جدا وسعيد لما اشوف مريض
قلبيه عم يطيب من مرضه وما مهمتي اني اخوض
حرب خمس سنوات ولم تحمل الثوره السوريه
السلاح لولا ان بشار الاسد وشبيحته ومجرمي
قتلوا واغتصبوا وحرقوا وهذا الكلام وهذا
الكلام اكدته اليوم وزاره الخارجيه
البريطانيه ح البريطانيه فنحن كلنا جميعا
نحلم باليوم الذي يعود فيه الاستقرار الى
سوريا وقلنا ونقول والتزمنا وذهبنا الى
جنيف اننا مع الحل السياسي الحل السياسي
المنطقي المعقول المقبول الذي يكون ضامن
لحقوق الشعب السوري لا ان يكون على حساب
مصالح الشعب السوري واي حياد عن هذا
الطريق لن يكون مقبولا ولا تعيرني
بالتضحيات انا اقول لك مستعد للوصول للحل
الان في طاوله مفاوضات جديه اما ان يبقى
الظالم فوق رقبتي وترغم مني بالحل فهذا
غير مقبول لن نقبل بنظام بشار الاسد مهما
كان الثمن هذا سيدي ليس خياري يعني ليس
يعني مزاو على التلفزيونات اذهب واسال اهل
المخيمات اذهب واسال المقاتلين الذين
يقدمون كل يوم قوافل من الشهداء ما رايكم
اخي ببقاء بشار الاسد لن يقبل احد بالعوده
الى بيته ان لم يتم التخلص من هذا المج
طيب انا اسالك دكتور عند اجتمع بشار الاسد
او استدعي الى الكرملين سمعنا من الرئيس
الروسي
حرفيا وهو لا يتحدث عن اي شيء في سوريا
سوى الارهاب طيب يعني يعني لا اريد ان
استخدم كلمات قويه بس يعني مش حرام على
الاقل تنسون انه في سوريا كانت هناك ثوره
تطالب بابسط حقوقها لم تعد ت يعني انتم
الروس لم تعودوا تؤمنون باي شيء في سوريا
الا
بالارهاب خطابكم لا يختلف
قيده انمله عن خطاب النظام انه نحن نواجه
ارهابيين وتكفير وكذا وقال بوتن امام بشار
الاسد في الكرملن قال نشكركم ونشد على
ايديكم لانكم تواجهون كل الارهاب لم يتحدث
لا عن حقوق شعب سوري ولا عن تضحيات شعب
سوري ولا عن ثوره شعب سوري ولا عن حرك
انتم الرئيس الروسي نفس الخطاب تبع
الشبيحه كما يقول لك نفس الخطاب تشبيح
بامتياز ما في ما في بامتياز ما فيوز
بالاحرى دكتور
اولا التدخل العسكري في روسيا هو في سوريا
هو موازي ل الحل السياسي نحن من اللحظات
طيب بس خليني اشرح لي اياها بس مشان
توصلها للسوريين انت جاي هالس خوي جاي
مئات الطائرات السخو الحديثه وجايب احدث
انواع الصواريخ وجايب احدث انواع الاسلحه
بدك تعمل لي حل سياسي بالله هذا القصف
بتاعكم والتدمير وقتل الاطفال والمدارس
والجامعات وكذا ودنيا هلا بدي اسالك سؤال
بدي اسالك سؤال انا عندي لا لا لا لا
دقيقه دقيقه لا لا ما بدي لا لا دقيقه
تقرير تقرير الجزيره امبارح بناء على
تقارير دوليه اه خمسه فقط بال من الغرات
الروسيه في سوريا تستهدف تنظيم الدوله اما
الباقي فكان على المعارضه السوريه ثانيا
72% ها هي 72% من الاهداف الروسيه حتى
نهايه الشهر الماضي كانت ذات طبيعه مدنيه
بحته جاي تقول لي جايب لي كل هال الاسلحه
وصواريخ اللي عم تستخدمو عم تجربوها فينا
عم تجربوها فينا وجاي بتقول لي بكل بكل
بروده لا لا بدك تحكي بس بكل بروده جاي
تقول لي دكتور زياد نحن جايين لحال سلمي
بربك دكتور يا دكتور يا دكتور اولا نسيت
ان تضيف ايضا تقرير امريكي يعني هل امريكا
وتركي اي وتركي وسعودي وكل التقارير طبعا
بدي تكتب الشيء اللي عمال بتحكي عليه كل
ضربه عسكريه في روس روسيا الى سوريا مصوره
ب بالفيديو في الزمان والمكان اذا في
شيطنه لروسيا في شيطنه اعلاميه ضد روسيا
هي اولا ثانيا بالنسبه للحل السلمي بدون
حل سلمي لن يكون هنالك مستقبل لس ط بس قل
لي كيف بك تعملوا الحل السلمي بهذه
الطائرات يجب ان ي كيف نحن البدايه كانت
هي ضرب المرافق الحيويه للمنظمات
الارهابيه الجيش الحر يتكلم عنه انه اين
هو الجيش الحر طبعا نتساءل اين الجيش الحر
اذا كان لا يوجد هنالك قياده موحده لا
يمكن ان تعلن موقفا صريحا او تدخل في
مباحثات مع القياده العسكريه الروسيه ليس
مع السياسيه لكي يه ليكون هنالك تجنبا
للضربات ال الروسيه لمواقع الجيش الحر
ثانيا نتكلم عن بس بس خليني بالنقطه مهمه
جدا انا ما بدي اقاطعك بس بدي مشان تشرح
له ل للانسان السوري الان اللي عم يشوفك
انه انت الانسان السوري عندما يرى احدث
صواريخك وطائراتكم وقنابل وكله هذا يقصف
السوريين يقصف السوريين يقتل المدنيين رح
يسالك انه بالله عن اي حال سياسي عم تحكي
انت نحن ضد قتل اي مدني في سوريا ما كله
بيحكي هيك يا زلمه هذا الكلام غير صحيح
دكتور فيصل اي المعلومات التي تقدم حتى من
طرف ال الجيش السوري او الاركان السوري
اركان الجيش السوري يتم فحصها
والتدقير الواقع هنالك في العمليه في
سوريا تظنون انه غرفه غرفتين تدير
العمليات هنالك اجهزه في الفضاء في اقمار
تتابع هذه المعلومات وتتاكد من هذه
المعلومات ماشي بس خليني اسالك سؤال انتم
مش جايين منان تقصفه داعش والارهابيين نعم
ماشي نعم
طيب امبارح الطائرات الروسيه قصفت درعا
ونحن نعرف بدرعا لا يوجد دواعش وممنوع
واهل درعا اول ناس ممكن يطلعوا لهم مشيك
يا دكتور انت من بصر الحرير ا جارنا انت
مش هيك
اه اهل درع بالدرجه الاولى سيتصدون لهم
واسال ال دعني اخوتنا في درعا سيقولون لك
اذا بنشوف واحد داعش يعني لماذا قصفته
امبارح بالجنوب بس دقيقه
دقيقه الح الجيش الحر طبعا له قائد جيش
الحر طبعا له قائد ط هذا القائد جيش الحر
ح الذي يغار على بلده واهل بلده ويريد
الحفاظ عليهم لماذا لا لا لا يقوم
بايجاد خط تواصل مع القوات الروسيه عن طري
على فكره هل تعلم بان هنالك اتصالات
وتنسيق مع الاردن طيب ماشي معرك طيب ماشي
بس انا بس بس خليني بس مشان نضح الفكره
منك بس بس مشان توضح لهم اياها لانه هذا
اللي مثار في الشارع الان في غوطه دمشق في
الغوطه هل هناك دواعش انت بتعرف زهران
علوش وجيش الاسلام صور له الشيطان الرجيم
ولا تصور له الدواعش يعني اسلام زهران
علوش واسلام مستعدين يفعلوا المستحيل كي
يمنعوا داعش من دخول المنطقه لماذا تقصف
دوما لماذا تقصف الغوطه الشرقيه لماذا
تقصف كل المناطق اللي ما فيها د داعش اذا
انتم قادمون باختصار للقضاء على كل من
يقول لا للنظام السوري واعاده تمكين هذا
النظام الطائفي العلوي الفاشي على رقاب
السوريين بس بيحلم مقاتلين داعش مقاتل
مقاتلين داعش موجودين حتى في الغوطه وحتى
موجودين حوالي الغوطه لا يمكن اليوم ان
تتكلم للمواطن السوري ونخمم هيك بكلمتين
انه غير متواجدين متواجدين حتى على ابواب
دمشق اها اذ لم يكن هنالك تنسيق مره اخرى
تنسيق ما بين قياده جيش الحر طيب جيش
الحر لا لا جيش الحر يقاتل النظام صحيح هو
عدو للجيش لنظام ويريد اسقاط النظام طيب
لو روسيا تعتبر جيش الحر منظمه ارهابيه هل
يمكن لروسيا في العلن ان تطلب التنسيق مع
جيش خل شي خليك شوي هذ نقطه خليك شوي طيب
دكتور هذا كلام منطقي انا بدي اسالك اذا
ثلاث نقاط قالهم الدكتور وبدي ترد عليهم
هناك حمله شيطنه اعلاميه منظمه ضد روسيا
وقالها الرئيس بوتين بعد ايام من بدء
الحمله في سوريا قال نحن نعلم بانه سيكون
ضدنا مش هيك قال حمله اعلاميه او شيطنه
لروسيا ونحن نعرف ى قبل بد اليه ح قب قدل
بد العمل طيب هذا نقطه انه في حميه شيطنه
ومش كل شيء بنسمعه انه روسيا تدمر الاطفال
وتقتل وتقتل هذه جزء من الحمله ضد روسيا
هذه من جهه من جهه ثانيه انتم تقولون انه
لا يستهدف داعش يستهدف فقط خمسه او 10%
ماكسيمم من داعش الدكتور يقول لك العمليات
الروسيه والقصف الروسي يصور بالفيديو مش
هيك ويعرض في التل وهذه الجماعات التي
يستهدفها القصف الروسي موجوده داعش لو لم
تكن موجوده لما قصفها كيف ترد عليه بس
هدول ولا ارد على كل شي تفضل اخي بشار
الاسد ما بده حل سياسي بشار الاسد ذهب الى
جنيف وافشل كل عمليه الحل السياسي وهذا
الموضوع يعني اعترف فيه المبعوث الاممي
المشترك الاخضر الابراهيمي وفعلا فشلت
عمليه استقل مثل ما افشل مبادرات الجامعه
العربيه والمبعوث الاول والمبعوث الثاني و
المراقبين لا تغير الان استدعي بشار الاسد
الى روسيا والان الوضع تغير روسيا قادمه
لاحلال سلام تمام اناعم بقول عن بشار
الاسد اثنين قبل فينا بساعات نحن لن ندخل
اي عمليه سياسيه حتى ننهي ملف
الارهاب رقم
ثلاث في الوقت اللي كان في اجتماع ب فينا
قصف يا جماعه يعني الشغله بدها شوي قصف
سوق شعبي سوق سوق دكتور شفت الصور شفت
البصات شفت النار شلون مولعب واحد عم يبيع
بصل اخضر وكسبرا وبقدونس يا رجل لو حتى لو
قصف مسلحين يعني ها بجوز نقول اخي اعداؤه
طبيعي الزلم مجرم بده يقتل من حدد جهه شب
من حدد الجهه التي قصفت اثنين اثنين ليش
ما ممكن يكون عمليه فتنه انه حتى من داعش
تم ضرب س يا رجل قص سوج وفي عندنا اطباء
بلا حدود وفي عندنا عشرات بمئات الناشطين
الحيادي جوا صاروا مرتبطين مع المنظمات
الدوليه ب دقيقه بس دقيقه لا بس دقيقه
دقيقه هذه بس مشان اكدها اطباء بلا حدود
هذا كلامهم لا كلامي ولا كلام الدكتور ولا
كلام الجيش الحر ولا حدا غارات روسيه على
12 مستشفى في سوريا تقتل خمسه
طبيبا ومسعف ومريضا هذه هي حرب الروس على
الارهاب بينما داعش تسرح وتمرح هذه شو
اسمه بلا حدود اطباء بلا حدود اه هذه مش
معموله بالث اه ماشي اكمل انا دخلتي سيدنا
اذا بشار الاسد خمس سنين لا قدر يقضي على
شويه عصابات مسلحه بدها تهز اركان نظامه
ولا قادر على داعش من 100 دوله ولا قادر
يحمي حدود ولا قادر يحمي قصره ولا قادر
يغادر دمشق ولا قادر يغادر يعود لدمشق
امام هيك علني انه اخي رئيس دوله طلع على
دوله اخرى زياره ليش محتفظين فيه هذا هذا
الرئيس برايك بعد عنده مقومات انه يصلح
هيك يقعد على كرسي الحكم ويقول يا جماعه
اعملوا لي مخبز هون وفتحوا لي جامعه هون
هذا الرئيس انتهى للاسف الشديد انه روسيا
تمارس سياسه مراوغه انا ما بدي اقول كلمه
اكثر مراوغه عندها خطابين خطاب بيد تقول
نحن مع الحل السياسي ونحن لا نتمسك ببش
بشار الاسد كشخص ونحن مؤسسات الدوله يحافظ
عليها بشار الاسد مؤسسات الدوله مؤ الدوله
وباليد الاخرى اجت عساس تحارب داعش وبلشت
قصف بالجيش الحر روسيا خلال العام الماضي
حاولت ان تنسف صيغه جنيف اثنين بكل
الوسائل لانها تنص على تشكيل هيئه الحكم
الانتقالي وحاولت ان توجد هياكل للمعارضه
هي ان لم تكن من صلب النظام فهي مقربه جدا
جدا من النظام حتى يعني تكون على يقين
يعني تريد معارضه على طريقه الجبهه
الوطنيه التقدميه بتاع حافظ الاسد
يعني يعني يعني يزودون حتى على البعص على
نظام البعص نعم وحاولت في الفتره الاخيره
ان يعني تسوق نظام بشار الاسد رئيس شرعي
ما شاء الله 88.6 جاب بالانتخابات وحكومه
شرعيه منتخبه وبدي تبني حلف دولي تشارك
فيه تركيا والسعوديه والاردن ونظام بشار
الاسد يعني تصغر الحلم شوي يعني يعني تصغر
الحلم اليوم تلم كل ه المتناقضات كله مشان
يعني عيون بشار الاسد مشان خاطر بشار
الاسد هذا الموضوع لم يعد مقبولا ولم يعد
ذو جدوه يعني يعني روسيا عم تتعب حالها
على الفاضي لا يمكن ان تنفخ الروح في جثه
هامده ما عاد صفى منه اي اي نتيجه القياده
الموحده للجيش الحر نعم قياده موحده الجيش
الحر اليوم كله موحد على انه لن يعود الى
بيته قبل رحيل بشار الاسد الجيش الحر
اليوم كله موحد على حفظ حدود سوريا
واستقلالها وعلى ان تكون سوريا كلها
للجميع وعلى انه اليوم هو يحمل لواء
التضحيه والبطوله نيابه عن كل الشعب
الموجود واللي لا يستطيع ان يشارك في هذه
المعركه الفاصله مع نظام بشار الاسد معقول
يا دكتور الروس بدهم يتواصلوا مع الجيش
الحر لحتى يقولوا لهم احنا موجودين هون لا
تضربونا هلا كل ضربات الروس للجيش الحر
خطا يعني لو الروس ضربوا داعش 95 والجيش
الحر خمسه اخي عذرا والله خربط هون شوي
تمام كل الضرب للجيش الحر بدهم الان الجيش
الحر ينسق معهم مشان يقولوا لهم لو كان
لدى الروس وهي كمان رساله ننقلها الى مجلس
الدوما اسمح لي يعني انا اسف ان لم يكن
مجلس الدوما يختلف عن مجلس الشعب تبعنا
مجلس الدوما تمام مجلس رساله اذا لو كان
لدى الروس نيه جديه للتحالف بعلاقات
استراتيجيه مع الشعب السوري سياسيين او
جيش حر او ثوار على الارض على اساس مصلحه
حقيقيه تؤدي الى تسويه تبعد هذا النظام
المجرم فهو مستعد تماما ان يدخل ويوقف
العدوان الغاشم على الشعب السوري فهو
مستعد تماما للانخراط بهذه المفاوضات اما
الجيش الحر والثوار دكتور مش يعني ناس
عاديين في منهم اساس ال جامعه واطباء
ومهندسين وقضاه وشرعي وطلاب بكالوريا
وطلاب تاسع ناس كوادر هذول بسوريا اليوم
لا يمكن يجلسوا مع الروس ت يقولوا لهم
دخيلك يا استاذ بوتن انا هون موجود لا
تضربني زيح لي الضربه شوي بعدين اخي هم
حتى الجيش الحر ما ضربوه عم يضربوا
المخابز يا دكتور بجيب لك المقاطع اللي في
انا مستعد اضمن لك دخول الى سوريا بشكل
امن وتكون تجربه اخي للروس تصل الى ابعد
نقطه قصف الروس وتعود الى اهلك سالم غانم
وانا اتعهد امام الجزيره والان ما بعرف
قديش ناس بيشاهدو ان تدخل امن باذن الله
تعالى وتطلع بام عينك على الاماكن التي
يقصفها الروس من ابناء سوريا وشيوخ سوريا
ونساء سوريا واطفال سوريا المشافي 12 مشفى
انضرب اللي هي مضيه ومشفى
بتير معل قلت لك مخبز جامع مزرعه عائله
كامله مثل ما هي مكان ثاني مبنى سكني سوق
شعبي بدومه كل هذا لاجبار بشار الاسد
لاجبار الشعب السوري على الصلح معشار
اعاده تمكين اعاده تمكين النظام ايران ما
قدرت للثور وحزب الله ما قدر للثوار
وميليشيات بالعشرات جابوها ما قدرت للثوار
الروس لن يغيروا شيء مصلحتهم الحقيقيه ان
يمدوا يد السلام مع الشعب السوري السور
طيب دكتور بس نقطه واحده بس مشان ما تروح
بدي اسالك نحن نعلم ان داعش لفتره طويله
كانت معظم عملياتها مركزه في الرقه وفي
دير الزور ومطار دير الزور بشكل عام و
واخر شيء تدمر وسكتت هناك طيب انت كيف
تفسر لي كمسؤول روسي الان اه انه داعش
الان اصبحت على وشك انه تقطع طريق حمص
دمشق هي موجوده الان بمين بثاني اكبر مخزن
للسلاح في سوريا اه هي موجوده مجوده في
القريتين هي موجوده في الصدد هي موجوده
تتقدم في حلب هل تستطيع ان تنكر
بانها استولت على مدرسه الم مدرسه المشات
طيب مدرسه المشات ايمت اخذتها بعد دخول
الروس ايمت اخذت خناصر واثريا والمنطقه
الحره وكله هذا في حلب بعد دخولكم يعني
انتم ان شاء الله بتقعدوا لكم شهرين ثلاثه
بعد هون في سوريا داعش بتاخذ سوريا
كلياتها دكتور اولا خطاب المعارض
او ما يسمي انفسهم بالمعارضه اليوم
والهجوم على روسيا والهجوم على التدخل
العسكري الروسي في سوريا لن يعطي نتيجه
جيده او يعطي فائده للشعب السوري وهذا
الخطاب يا دكتور نصر سوف يجعل او سوف يهدم
ما بقي من سوريا هذا الخطاب ليس خطابا
سياسيا في السياسه يوجد شيء هو خطاب
الممكن اليوم يجب ان تتكلم ما يمكن
للمعارضه اليوم ان تحصل على مكتسبات
للمشاركه في السلطه وليس في الحكم اذا كان
اليوم هذا الكلام والجيش الحر وهذا الكلام
كلياته يعني لن ياتي بنتيجه روسيا لم تطلب
من الجيش الحر المواقع لكي تقوم بقصفها او
لكي تعرف مواقع جيش الحر روسيا ارادت ان
توري المواطن السوري اللي الان عمال بيسمع
لنا انه نحن لا لم ناتي لنضرب الثوار او
للجيش الحر نحن حربنا فقط مع الارهاب
تاييد للنظام المتواجد الان اليوم رئيس
الجمهوريه هو بشار الاسد بعد بالنسبه لل
انه يجب ان يرحل دكتور لا يوجد هنالك في
علم السياسه واو في علم الحوار انه يجب ان
تكون النتيجه مضمونه قبل ان تقوم بخطوات
صغيره الوضع في سوريا وصل الى ازمه جدا
جدا ازمه معقده جدا يجب ان نقول اليوم لل
المن السوري المواطن العربي يا جماعه نحن
وصلنا الى طريق مسدود ليس من العيب ان
تعترف باخطاء ورتم الشعب السوري اليوم في
في في امر ليس من قدرته ابدا ماشي بس
دكتور بس ممكن اسالك سؤال طيب انتم كيف
تكونون فقدان الدوله
لاداره ان كان في المحافظات الشرقيه او
الشماليه هذا شيء عادي في ظروف الحرب
اليوم الحل في سوريا لا يمكن ان يكون حلا
واحدا يجب ان يكون حلا من عده خطوات على
مراحل
نعب رو مدت وتريد ان تمد يدها السوريين ل
مقدمتك دكتور فيصل تكلمت عن حرب تشرين
التحريريه عندما كان يصفق
السوريون هل تعلم ايضا هنالك شهداء من
الروس والسوفيت عندها في حر التحريريه
دكتور دكتور انا بسان بس نقطه انا لا انكر
ذلك انا كنت صغير بذلك الوقت كنت اطلع على
السطح وصفق ل لسام لسام وهو يسقط الطائرات
الاسرائيليه بس الان بعد ان بداتم تقصف
نحن الشعب السوري والله نحن متمنين انه
الشيطان الرجيب يسقط عرضت علي ان ازور
سوريا واصل الى نقطه وانا ايضا امام
الجزيره وامام الشعب السوري كمان انا جاهز
اي وفد من قبل الجيش الحر او المعارضه
السياسيه ان تزور حتى سوريا او حتى ان
تزور موسكو يجب ان يكون هنالك لقاءات وجه
لوجه ان تتخبا حول جهات اقليميه هذا امر
ليس مجديا ابدا طيب بس بس خليني بس مشان
الوقت يداهمنا كيف تبرر او كيف تشرح
للانسان السوري الان اللي عم يسمعك انه
انتم قادمون من اجل ايجاد حل من من اجل
انقاذ سوريا طيب كيف تدعون الى حل سياسي
في سوريا وقد اصبحتم انتم الروس الخصم
والحكم انتم عاوزين تكونوا حكم بس بنفس
الوقت عم تقصف يعني انتم صرتوا انتم عم
تقولوا نحن مع النظام يا دكتور كيف بدي
اصدقك انه انت عم تقصف مع النظام وبتست
قبل بشار الاسد في الكرملين وبتقول لهكذا
وبتقول لي تاعد اعمل حل انا وسيط انت غير
نزيه غير وقبل وتستقبل اسد في الكرملين
وتقول له يجب ان يكون هنالك حلا سياس يجب
ق ما قول ما قيل للاسد بانه يجب ان يكون
هنالك حلا سياسيا يرضي جميع الفئات وهو
يقول لكم اليوم لا حل سياسي في سوريا قبل
القضاء على داعش ونحن ضد المرحله
الانتقاليه ماذا تقول له اقول له يجب ان
يكون هنالك عمليه متوازيه الحرب مع
الارهاب والحل السياسي يجب ان يسيان
متوازيان هذا عكس كلام بشار الاسد بشكل
متوازي الامر اصبح قضيه دوليه التدخل
الروسي دكتور نصر امريكا واوروبا سووا
حالهم شيء غريب انا اعلن لك رسميا قبل
التدخل الروسي امريكا كانت على علم وقبل
التدخل العسكري المباشر في سوريا سفير
روسيا في العراق ابلغ السفير الامريكي في
بغداد لفرق الزمن لان نحن بعد ساعه سوف
نتدخل عسكريا هي معلومات اوكي دكتور ارجو
منك رجاء وحيد ان لا تخادع الشعب السوري
لا تبنوا له احلام ورديه المسيره كما
تتصورون هي جدا جدا طويله سوف تؤدي الى
القضاء على سوريا كدوله في 27 28 عندما
كذا اللقاء في فينا رئيس المخابرات
الفرنسيه في نفس اليوم رئيس المخاب كما
كان يعود قبل ان كما كان من قبل يعني هذول
هل يتكلمون من الهواء في نفس الوقت وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي والفرنسي والروسي
متواجدين واصدروا بيان انه نحن مع بناء
دوله مدنيه
علمانيه تحفظ كل الطوائف وهي اعطوا اشاره
للاخوان المسلمين انه لا ي لا يمكن ان
يكون دورا لفصائل اسلاميه في الحكم وقد
اخذوا الدرس من من مصر عم بقول لك لن يكون
هنالك لن تعود سوريا بحدودها ام صحيح قال
وزير المخبره طيب بس انا خليني اس دكتور
نصر كيف ترد على هذا الكلام انه هل تستطيع
ان تنكر الان اه انه هناك مباركه دوليه
اتفاق دولي يعني اذا كنتم تراهنون على ان
روسيا ستت وط في سوريا كما تورطت في
افغانستان انتم تحلمون انتهى الوضع الان
اليوم سمعنا اخبار عن تنسيق روسي امريكي
في الاجواء السوريه و حدث ولا حرج عن
التنسيق ومناورات جويه وحدث ولا حرج عن
التنسيق الروسي الاسرائيلي بدي اسالك
بالله دكتور انت يعني سيد العارفين عندما
تنسق روسيا واسرائيل في سوريا شو بيطلع
لكم بالله بعد هذا شو بيطلع لكم نحن ظلوا
يضحكوا علينا يقولوا لنا انه اسرا قال
هناك تنسيق عربي والعرب خوانين وما بعرف
شو العرب الثانيين قال عم نسقوا مع
اسرائيل في سوريا طلعت اسرائيل عم بتنسق
مع ايران ومع حزب الله ومع بشار الاسد
الروس في سوريا ومع الثوار ايضا وتستقبل
جرح الثوار وتعالج وتعيدهم الى الاراض
السوريه الان الان الان كما يقول لك
الدكتور لا تحلموا بانه سوريا روسيا تتورط
في في سوريا الامريكان يباركون عندما
تبارك اسرائيل وعندما يلتقي نتنياهو و
وبوتين مرتين خلال اسبوعين فانتم وين
رايحين يعني طيب ا باختصار لو تكرمت اول
شيء يعني حسب الترتيب اللي مسجله انا هون
الموضوع دكتور زياد مه موضوع خ طب انا قلت
لك احنا رحنا على جنيف اثنين بناء على
شرعيه دوليه ما كانوا السوريين حاضرين
فيها اصلا
وقبلنا شرعيه فيها الدول دائمه العضويه
الخمسه في مجلس الامن ومنها روسيا وفيها
الامم المتحده وفيها دول اخرى وهذه
المرجعيه تنص على حل هيئه حكم انتقالي
باليه التوافق المتن مع هذه
الوثيقه وذهبنا الى جنيف اثنين ولم تكن لا
روسيا ولا النظام جاده اليوم روسيا
وحلفائها تسعى الى خل صيغه جديده حتى انه
هيئه الحكم الانتقالي في البيان اللي كتب
بفينا ما رضوا يكتبوه كتبوا الحكم وفيصل
مقداد اليوم يتحدث عن حوار وطني وحكومه
موسعه يعني ما في هذا هذا الكلام واح يجب
ان تشير انه كانت هي جلسات استشاريه نعم
نعم اثنين اخي بالنسبه للزياره للزياره
لموسكو يعني معقوله اذا كانت روحها لها
اهميه ويوافق عليها توافق عليها الفصائل
ويوافق عليها الائتلاف هذا الامر بس زياره
على سوريا انا انصحك لا تورط حالك بانه
تتبنى اي زياره على سوريا نظام بشار الاسد
نظام امني دكتاتوري لا يوثق به بيوفر لك
100 حجه لحتى يقول لك اخي خطا اخي قتلوه
جيش الاسلام قتلوه داعش اخي قصفه لهذا
الزلمه اثنين هل الحل دكتور حتى نبقي يعني
ها الحجه او الشماعه سوريا راحت سوريا
راحت سوريا راحت هل هذا اللي قال الاسد او
نحرق البلد او ادمر كل شيء هل هذا الزلمه
ما اليوم الروس لها اي واحد يقوله خيو خلص
خلصت اللعبه او الحل انه يجوا مليونين
قاتل وجريح مقتول وجريح
وشهيد رل غبي مهما
اليوم اليوم التنسيق الاسرائيلي الروسي
الايراني هذا كشف كل شي هذا كشف
اللعبه
كانش تخوف من اسرايل انته
الوقت للاسف الشديد اشكرك مشكورين جدا
يعطكم الف عافي مشاهدي الكرام هل تؤيد
الحل السياسي الروسي في سوريا نعم 9.8 لا
90.2 لم يبقى لنا ل نشكر ضيفين الدكتور
السناتور زياد سبسبي والدكتور نصر الحريري
نلتقي مساء الثلاثاء المقبل فحتى ذلك
الحين هو فيصل قاسم يحييكم من الدوحه الى
اللقاء يعطيكم العافيه يا
[موسيقى]
جماعه i